your inner purpose is to awaken
that is an essential part of the purpose
of the whole
the universe and its emerging
intelligence
your outer purpose can change over time
finding and living
in alignment with your inner purpose is
the foundation for fulfilling
your outer purpose
that one took me a while to digest as i
was going through it
you know we if we were created by god as
god's divine children and it's our
destiny to be companions and co-creators
with him throughout eternity
at least according to the edgar cayce
readings we might call that
in looking at it from this filter
through eckhart tolle we might call that
our inner purpose while the outer
purpose
is to patiently work with whatever we
find at hand to manifest god's love and
whatever we do
all right so if we're looking at this in
terms of
your outer purpose can change over time
so when we have one lifetime to another
one job to another one spouse to another
one you know
one friendship to another all of those
things can wind up having
what we do in the outer purpose and our
interactions with the universe
that changes over time okay but what is
the inner purpose
it's the essential part of the whole the
universe and its emerging
intelligence we are always trying to
awaken
who we are and always keep in mind that
we are the divine
children and siblings of a god of
unconditional love
the ego will always try to add
awakening and enlightenment to itself as
its most
prized possession in so doing the ego
becomes bigger
and is itself more important than such
things
isn't that true if you wind up owning
you know you feel like
i own this thing therefore i you know
it's one of my
trophies that i have out there and if
this is something that i own and control
then i must be
even greater than what it is right so
greatness
is a mental abstraction and a favorite
fantasy of the ego
the paradox is that the foundation for
greatness
is honoring the small things of the
present moment
instead of pursuing the idea of
greatness
now the uh i
think i wrote of course casey uh
definitely quoted the bible when he was
talking about if you want to be the
master
you know if you want to be the messiah
the master the savior you must be the
servant of all as well
and that was at the last supper you
remember where he got down and he washed
the
the feet of the of the disciples
so if you think of all of the earthly
rulers not jesus but the earthly rulers
throughout history
they paid an awful lot of attention to
conquer the earth as well as all of
their perceived enemies right so they're
like
i'm gonna beat them up and take them
over and control this
but how much attention did they pay to
the plight of their own people
that they had people within their own
ranks that were hungry or those that
were injured and you know they went into
war and
they said oh sucks to be here you got
your arm cut off i can't use you anymore
all right but god knows the number of
hairs on the head of each one of us and
he supplies
every need that we have the bible tells
us that as well in case he quotes it
so a such attention of the tiniest
detail from our greatest servant
who would be jesus slash god is
absolutely true greatness all right
so when we're we're talking about what
is greatness here
greatness is when you take care of your
neighbor when you see
that where you can be a service and you
take those small steps
in order to be of service to other folks
like that is greatness being able to say
i
am ruler of the world no because then
you're going to die and then you're not
so then it's all over and it's uh you
know when you see i love that buffer
sticker it says he who dies with the
most toys wins
wins what
you got nothing to show for it but yet
there it is